but I I'm happy to be your man I
appreciate you having me
yeah I love animals and I love you I've
always loved you man
I don't know when I met you when did I
meet you mmm terms like how big you were
whenever we met probably same size so
probably maybe six years ago in a long
time
you know I mean but when I met you I
went [ __ ] this white dude right here is
he funny my son go up man dang he sounds
very ha the Latin Kings no bro just you
gotta be this [ __ ] he funny to
work right urban bow on stable killing
that guy [ __ ] you went up there dude
he's [ __ ] got weird [ __ ] bro Oishi his
point of view and [ __ ] about like we're
here from his pigeon era Jesus about
seeing about uncle and chimes I'm all
kinds of [ __ ] do and I was like dude
he's one of us bro yeah I saw him
another time do him and I did some jerk
me off by a dumpster do that excuse me
what we work together we work together
where I had a jerk Theo off oh I didn't
literally jerk him off at a dumpster
dude you do what I do in the hotel room
Bonnie for now bah but it was Meisner we
really I think we touched yeah but you
know what I'm saying yeah we really did
it yeah yeah cuz I don't have any I
hardly have any feelings left in my
penis anyway I feel like at this age
oh really and I'm not trying to be weird
and wait because of a lot of
masturbation or you get a lot of girls I
think it's a mix of everything man
you know I've been with some decent
women and some just troubled women and
some undervalued women all right and you
still you still hook up with the ugly
ones or what no these days I mean you
know I try to find uh and then you know
a little bit of beauty and everybody but
sometimes you got to really get in there
to see it yeah I mean like right I know
what you're saying what you're saying is
to me this it's like you're okay you
meet a girl online or whatever yeah and
their face is fine legit right and then
their body is legit right then you get
them naked and then some things aren't
legit is that what you're saying yeah
the foundation is weak whatever I always
said you can't build a house on sand
come on except Angkor Wat was built on
sand Angkor Wat and Komodo what this guy
right here I don't know right here Razia
yes so but do you don't trust him though
do you mean look out be real you want
honesty know what I'm gonna see him I
think that you know he probably grew up
in a place and had like a lot of chimes
and stuff and a lot of cartons on rugs
on the wall yeah yeah yeah ceiling on
the floor yeah I know what you're saying
though is a mix match a lot of places
they put rugs on the wall instead of the
floor what is the kitchen look like yeah
the kitchen a lot of utensils yes yes
giant one giant yeah a couple of older
Sammy's that look either that could be
men or women how do my parents talk they
don't talk anymore
read all kinds of stuff just do the eyes
nah bro yeah but there's a lot of love
in there but the lows all it's a lot of
loves historical so it's already been
built in
you're not getting like a lot of it
these days it's just kind of no yeah but
it's really no no you feel it yeah when
I first met you dude I didn't trust you
yeah because you came in there like a
[ __ ] yellow butterfly you've been
zipping and zipping and out with the
ginger maggot it's just somebody that uh
I'm huh I've got some a buddy my Kendra
town with some sick ginger bro enough so
I've been on that for like two days
what you mean like like real ginger the
route yeah good meal from Hawaii
I wouldn't say Hawaii no but somewhere
closer than in town are you being real
he came out of town
this guy's rule rule ginger root stuff
and McGee you can't even close your eyes
dude and then and then you make a juice
out of it is that what you do some some
you eat if you get like real on the
inside part you eat it
we juice some of it you can cut it up
and put it in a eggs but it's strong bro
yeah make your neck bro bro I love
ginger myself dude yeah be on the street
they used to go there was a sign that
said we only have Hawaiian ginger and
that for some reason just because they
put the sign up made it seem even more
potent yeah like you're right if they
hadn't put out they're like oh this is
regular ginger yeah but they it was like
a warning we only have Hawaiian ginger
yeah
which scared the [ __ ] out of us let's
like drink it anyway you know me that's
a gay maker right there ginger boy if
you had to pick one spice it's a real
gay maker I think what do you mean by
that man just you get enough ginger in
your man you don't even see gender
really yeah yeah maybe luck is good
yeah you'll [ __ ] damn breeze try it
you'll try to [ __ ] a breeze pass let me
ask you something man
you'll [ __ ] anything I feel stick around
your body have a strong breeze a mist
[Music]